stratford-uneven district council is
currently consulting on a psyc
allocations plan
and we want to hear your views to follow
up on my previous video about reserve
sites here i discuss how we propose to
release them
the site allocations plan identifies
around 3 100 homes for reserve housing
sites
we don't want to release them all in one
go so sap 3 sets out a release mechanism
so that the sites can be released in
smaller batches or tranches
that more closely correspond with the
need
sites will be released following the
hierarchy establishing policy cs15 of
the core strategy
starting with stratford-upon-avon as the
main town moving to the main rural
centres and then down through the four
categories of local service village
we've also adjusted the density
assumptions and applied lower densities
to sites in the smaller villages
to help ensure that the focus of any
development is in the larger and more
sustainable locations the tranches are
set out in annex
3 of the site allocations plan now
bear with me because this is where it
gets a little complicated
within each of the tiers just mentioned
we have subdivided the settlements into
smaller tranches in order to better
manage the release of reserve sites
for the local service villages we have
taken account of those villages with a
made neighborhood plan that identifies
reserve sites
those villages that have already met
their indicative core strategy housing
numbers
and those villages that have
significantly exceeded their indicative
core strategy housing numbers
for the main rural centres we have taken
account of those villages with a main
new
vader neighborhood plan that identifies
reserve sites
unlike local service villages there are
no indicative housing targets for the
main rural centres
so reflecting national policy and the
role of smaller sites in terms of speedy
delivery
we've applied site-sized thresholds to
identify
the different tranches because of the
way the sites have been identified it is
also proposed to vary the tranches
depending on the purpose the sites are
needed for
so just to recap the way the release
mechanism works is that if the council
accepts that it needs to release reserve
sites it will in the first instance
start with those sites in
stratford-upon-avon town
if further sites are needed it will then
release sites in the main rural centres
working through the tranches as
necessary before moving on to the local
service villages
again working through the tranches in
order
we will confirm the need to release
sites and which ones based on up-to-date
information
about any infrastructure and delivery
constraints through decision of the
cabinet
reserve sites exist to meet for four
very different purposes
and none with the exception of
birmingham have yet been quantified or
confirmed
as such it is appropriate to ensure that
there is some reserve available for each
of the four purposes
for this reason the council is proposing
to cap any release to a thousand homes
in the first
instance if a purpose is satisfied by
fewer than a thousand homes
these would then be made available for
the remaining purposes
i hope that helps and our release
mechanism is now a little clearer
remember to find out more and have your
say go to www.stratford.gov dot uk
forward slash zappo